[Musique]
c'est au siège du département de la
réunion que s'est tenue la première
conférence des financeurs de la
prévention de la perte d'autonomie des
personnes âgées
un dispositif qui fait suite à la loi as
v du 28 décembre 2015 sur l'adaptation
de la société au vieillissement
cette conférence des financeurs et
présidée par le département de la
réunion et aurait composé de l'ensemble
des acteurs qui oeuvrent au quotidien
pour le maintien à domicile des
personnes âgées
et c'est important de travailler sur
cette notion de maintien de la cible
parce qu'aujourd'hui on a vraiment un
contexte socio démocrates ifo
sociaux-démocrates démographique pavot
et évolue et qui est qui va nous faire
et nous oblige à redéfinir à réinventer
la politique de maintien pour nos aînés
à la réunion entre 1980 et 2000 13 le
nombre de personnes de plus de 65 ans a
triplé
une population fragile et précaire
fortement touché par la perte
d'autonomie
la conférence des financeurs prévoit de
coordonner les actions envers ces
personnes et de favoriser le maintien à
domicile
il ya deux grands axes il ya la kz2 la
prise en charge de l'amélioration de la
prise en charge des personnes âgées
dépendantes
ce qu'on appelait le personnage et qui
sont dans des gir 1 à 4
et puis le deuxième axe c'est augmenter
les actions de prévention à destination
des personnes âgées encore autonome pour
faire en sorte qu'elle reste le plus
longtemps possible à leur domicile dans
les meilleures conditions possibles
alors oui il ya des choses qui se font
mais elles se font individuellement sans
vraiment le coordination territoriale ni
de coordination j'ai envie de dire
politique pour l'exercice 2010 est la
conférence des financeurs dispose d'une
enveloppe de 1 million 95 mille euros
pour mutualiser et coordonner ces
différentes actions de prévention en
faveur des personnes âgées
cette nouvelle instance définira une
nouvelle organisation une stratégie
locale de la prévention de la dépendance
à l'arrêt je pense qu'il ya une
minoration qui est extrêmement
importante comporte là c'est bien sûr
coordonner les financeurs coordonner les
actions en assurer le suivi
territoriale et ça je crois que c'est
souvent un grand problème
les acteurs font ici là des choses mais
pas coordonnées sur le terrain pour
telle et telle population ça ça va
changer grâce à la conférence financière
[Musique]